foreign
comes from Nick in Florida I know you
don't recommend credit cards but what
are your thoughts on debit card extra
and prepaid charge cards that say they
help build your credit
so extra is the name of a specific debit
card company out there that kind of
operates like a credit card by helping
you build your credit because they spot
you so just make a purchase and you
temporarily go into debt and then
they'll spot you and pay it off quickly
so that's the idea behind extra and it's
similar to some of these prepaid charge
cards secured it's technically not one
of these secured credit cards yeah and
the way secured credit cards work is you
pay an upfront deposit of one to two
times your credit limit and if you don't
pay they keep your deposit that's what
makes it secure there's collateral
involved yeah but with with these extra
cards here's what I don't like a I don't
like that they're marketing it as a
debit card because technically that
makes it sound like you're using your
own card and they're just monitoring
your accounts and that's not true at all
you do have to spend on their account
yep and they and I actually I don't know
I actually called extra because I wanted
to know more about this
um because I've had other people ask
about this and I asked them I was like
so how does this work and he was like
you spend the money on our card first
and then we go back in your account and
pull the funds out but it can take three
up to three days for them to pull that
money out so if from the time that you
make that purchase as many times do if
something comes out of your account
unexpected and suddenly you don't have
you can't fit the bill for 300 or
however much you spent on your extra
card suddenly like that has the ability
to go to collections and they'll send it
to collections within 30 days yes and so
the heart of this is to build credit the
people who are using this product they
have bad credit they have mismanaged
money they haven't made payments instead
of going well I may not be able to get
the credit card it has higher interest
so I'm going to turn to this extra card
here's the problem extra ain't free it
costs you 240 to 300 bucks a year
depending on the plan you choose and
then the other thing they get you with
is oh we have rewards too so they're
using the same marketing tactics as the
credit card companies to get you to
overspend with money you already didn't
have which is part of the reason you
have bad credit to begin with that makes
sense I mean there's even bit I mean yes
is the bad credit people but then
there's even been people who are like
hey I'm kind of like doing you guys's
plan ish but I still kind of care about
my credit score maybe I can use this to
still kind of have a credit score even
though I don't want to borrow money in
quotes and I think like that's just one
of those dangerous things where it's
like hey you you gotta you gotta buy all
into this you either are saying I don't
I'm living a life without debt I don't
care about my credit score and I can
rock my life with a zero credit score or
you're on the fence and you're playing
in these games where you mess around and
get you get burned man yeah at the heart
of the question of building my credit
the solution is not to build your credit
it's to get rid of it facts and that
scares so many people because we've
believed the myth and we've touted this
myth that FICO is Almighty and you gotta
have a good score to survive and I'm out
here going what do you need a score for
to go into more debt and what does that
do helps you get a better score if you
pay it off perfectly and play kissy face
with the bank so that you can go get
more debt yes and the only legitimate
question is well how do I get a house
without a credit score and I I made a
whole video about this on my new YouTube
channel Jade because I was so angry at
everyone going this guy's lying after I
said no I'm telling you I did it I'm not
like pitching this as a theory Jade has
done this too yes and I have to say this
because I look I'ma catch the Flack for
it but I he I see you guys in the
comments talking about well George is
easy for you you've got white skin no no
no I'ma squash that I'm gonna put the
smoke on that right now thank you it
does not matter what you look like if
you are out here in in these Americas in
this United States you can pay off your
debt you can live a life with no credit
you can get a zero credit score loan I
did it I've done it before so don't just
say oh George did it because of the way
he looks don't be judged in a book by
its cover my dad's from Egypt okay I
know another language what do you know
Jack squat okay down in the comment
section come through George I'm proud of
you thank you speak up on that and James
here I feel Brave and the thing is we're
not trying to yell at you we just want
you to know what's possible
believe all that noise out there that
says
educible Force for somebody quote
someone like me to get ahead that's not
true we believe more for you this is the
Ramsay show